you know I look at it is like fixing an
engine and it's like you got to learn
how to build simpler engines before you
get to a highly complex one like you
can't just walk in and build you know a
six cylinder where you're like I know
exactly how this runs you got to build a
little [ __ ] go-cart engine and then a
dirt you know you got to learn as you
build up and I I wish I could've started
comedy with that joke about my dead dad
but it took me you know 15 years to find
out okay what's the angle where it's I
can show everyone that I think the
situation is funny bombing is the
soreness in comedic exercise it's like
if you if you're really sore then you
need to work out more you need to be up
there more and it's like there it's
always gonna there's gonna be a soreness
with it because you're like man I've had
mornings where I've woken up and I've
been like goddammit that last show like
I'll do three shows at the stand in the
first two I'll be like looks like I
found what I was born on this earth to
do and then the third show would be like
hey should I kill myself by eating my
own [ __ ] that last crowd couldn't have
cared less a year or two under your belt
to kind of understand how comedy feels
in whatever city you started or wherever
city you live in spend about a year
learning with Ian you know low stakes
man go do open mics that that are
stressful as [ __ ] to you but when you
look back 15 years later you're a guy
that wasn't [ __ ] so go do those like
it's you know at the beginning of every
video game where you have the really
first easy level and it's just kind of
there to teach you the controls of the
game that's what your local scene is go
do that level and run run through it
once or twice and then move the
difficulty too hard and move to a hub
move to New York or LA or Chicago or a
city where you're gonna be around people
that scare you and make you feel wrong
that you're doing this but also there's
a weird inspiration of like I'll catch
up to you guys all I'll make it
I'll get to you where you guys are at a
great book that comedians should read
helps with comedy I think and I'm about
to reread it is how to win an argument
by Cicero I read it before I did fringe
it made me I kept thinking about this
during the Fringe Festival which was
like when you have an idea cast a very
wide net so that when you pull it back
you've gone through everything so when
you have an idea like cast the widest
net possible to see what you can catch
in it and then when you pull it all back
in you'll have you'll know you went
everywhere with the idea so where you
settle will be the best idea this is
specifically for comedians is understand
that the the people that work at those
comedy clubs might not be the biggest
comedy fans but they're the most
important because just as easily is
without us they're just a room with
tables and booze without them were just
crazy people yelling under a bridge so
be decent to every venue manager even if
they're a dick just be decent to him
unless they're like [ __ ] you know
like sexist or trying to rape you or
being racist or some [ __ ] like then [ __ ]
them
but I'm saying no that like most of the
servers there this wasn't their first
option to work at a [ __ ] funny bone
you know what I mean there's some people
that are but there's a lot of people
that are like I got hired at the funny
bone I'm kind of a fan of stand-up be
cool to them if you're serious about
becoming a comedian join our Facebook
group linked in the description below to
start getting tips like these every
single day and watch this playlist of
our top writing tips to improve your
writing today
[Music]